joining us now Fox News contributor Karl
Rove you know I want to look at the
magnitude of this Karl in through a
political prism we are going to watch
this week because we got a preview
speaking of South Carolina this weekend
of how radical how extreme this
Democratic New Democratic Socialist
Party has become but more importantly
they're all creating a circular firing
squad they're all trying to out out out
socialist the next one and destroy their
opponents but yeah add to this this all
happened on Biden Obama's watch you add
to this Devin Nunez warned about this in
2014 the Russians would do this they let
it happen they did nothing to prevent it
well that's not exactly right because we
have the President Obama saying that he
was going to speak sharply to Vladimir
Putin I'm sure that when Putin left that
meeting with them or President Obama
shaking in his boots and asking himself
why he'd never even thought about trying
to interfere in the u.s. elections I'm
obviously being a little sarcastic here
the President Obama now says that's the
reason and his defenders now say that
the reason that he did not issue a more
public denunciation of the Russian
efforts was they didn't want to draw
attention to it but look you're right
and this happened on their watch I hope
and every indication is is that the
government is going to take firm steps
to keep any foreign government or
foreign actors from participating
similarly in the 2020 presidential
elections and I'm sure every American
thinks that's wise
Carl you're a pretty smart guy you've
been around politics so round or two
maybe longer
like me and you know you see the
Democrats so excited to have Muller and
I'm thinking I know Jim Jordan and Mark
Meadows and I've read their closed-door
questioning of many people involved in
this and it's been fairly to be honest
brutal and they have exposed a lot
I don't believe and the things we talked
about how does he justify hiring
Hillary's attorney only Democrats had as
the answer the question about is nine
and a half minutes press conference that
he screwed up badly
how does he mentioned the question their
time prefer or taxi medallions
loan applications and taxes abroad
mandate that didn't include a dirty
Russian dossier paid for by the other
candidate
well I that that's one way of looking at
it can I look at it from a different way
since the Muller report came out two
things have happened
the president's favorables and
unfavorables have stabilized and the
percentage of people who say they don't
want to go through impeachment and don't
think impeachment is justified has risen
dramatically so what has happened with
their Mullah report is the American
people heard all about it
many of them went out and bought copies
about a copies of it many of them heard
about it on cable TV and on the internet
for four enormous amount of time and
what they did is they said they've
decided essentially unless you are a
hardcore Democrat unless you have
already condemned Donald Trump not only
to impeachment but to prison if you're
if you're a normal and ordinary American
who doesn't have those strong partisan
opinions the malla report led you to say
it's over now this is a problem for the
Democrats the longer they talk about
impeachment the more they appear to be
bent upon investigating the president
and that alone the more the American
people are going to conclude hey those
people don't have our best interest at
heart and and think about this the
number one message of the Democrats
today is investigate and impeach number
two message and growing up you know
getting close to it is the Bernie
Sanders Elizabeth Warren Democratic
presidential candidate message of free
everything free college we're gonna
forgive your dad so we're gonna have a
guaranteed basic income thousand dollars
a check every month for every American
we're gonna have Medicare for all
abolish your private insurance have the
government taken over I mean free
everything guaranteed federal job
all these lunatic proposals that we hear
from the campaign trail that's the
second message where is the winning
message for the Democrats in either one
of those two things so callers
appearance before the Senate ever before
the house excuse me I think sure
Republicans are gonna ask him some tough
questions and they deserve answers on on
those yet but I think that general and
the general impression is going to be
this is over why are we keep talking
about it and by the way he said all he's
got to do is repeat that so example you
do it accurately and not have the
Attorney General Bell
Mountain a joint statement later Karl
Rove good to see you thank you for being
with us